If you think rocket science sounds difficult.
Just wait until I tell you about this company,
SpaceRyde. Instead of just launching rockets
from the ground, they use balloons to carry
rockets into the upper atmosphere before launching
them. And surprisingly, it actually works! At the
center of the project is this guy: “My name is
Sohrab Haghighat and I’m the co-founder and CEO
of SpaceRyde” He’s a super talented engineer based
in Canada and he’s been building this company for
the past five years. Recently, we’ve seen a bit of
an arms race to build bigger and bigger rockets.
Starship usually gets all the attention, and for
good reason. It can deliver a payload of a hundred
metric tons to low earth orbit. SpaceRyde on
the other hand, can only deliver about a hundred
kilos. That’s a thousand times less. But there’s
actually a very good reason for this approach.
“What I want to do is enable small satellites
and small payloads that are going to space
so they can achieve their mission” 1:34 See, the
space industry is growing so quickly now that
there are needs at both ends of the payload
spectrum. Starship and bigger rockets will
obviously be incredibly important for huge
payloads, but the high price can lock out
smaller projects. Ridesharing on SpaceX rockets
will work for some companies, but you’ll still
need to deal with narrow launch schedules. If
SpaceX is building a massive eighteen wheeler,
SpaceRyde is building a taxi service. It’s highly
customizable and incredibly affordable. So let’s
dig into how this all works. SpaceRyde combines
three main technologies to deliver payloads to low
earth orbit. The first is the balloon and this
is by far the easiest part. But before we talk
about how the balloon works, we need to answer the
obvious question of why you would even want to use
a balloon in the first place. Well, even though
we don’t notice it when we’re just walking around.
The atmosphere is actually pretty thick down here
on earth. All the air creates an incredible amount
of drag on a rocket while it’s taking off. If
you want to counteract this drag, you just need
more power, which means a bigger rocket. That,
of course, means even more drag. This isn’t a
problem for big rockets with big payloads, but
if you're trying to deliver smaller payloads,
you’ll wind up wasting lots of energy just
plowing through the first layer of Earth’s
atmosphere. “You need a cheat and the balloon is
our cheat, since it gives you a free ride to the
edge of the atmosphere” - 2:55 There’s another
benefit though. During every rocket launch,
at some point you’ll hear the ground crew
say “we’ve reached MaxQ”. What that means
is that the rocket has just reached the
air pressure limits due to the atmosphere,
and it needs to throttle back. When you launch a
balloon 30 kilometers above the ground, MaxQ isn’t
an issue, so you can design a completely different
rocket. Sohrab and his team have done just that,
but before we dive into their rocket design, let’s
talk about the history of space balloons. Now, I
don’t know anyone who would watch a balloon launch
over a rocket launch, but they’re actually an
incredibly important part of modern science. NASA
alone launches a new mission every month through
their Scientific Balloon Program. And balloons
are so simple to make that even high-school
students can launch stuff into space using them.
Balloons are incredibly reliable at this point,
but more importantly, they are incredibly cheap.
“So the balloon as far as we care about it is a
commodity. So we buy our balloon.” The balloons
they use are made out of simple plastic materials,
not unlike a shopping bag. And they fill it
with hydrogen gas, which provides plenty of
lift capacity and is extremely affordable.
If you’re ever looking at prices of anything
in the space industry, you’ll be shocked to find
anything selling for less than a million dollars.
Even small parts on big rockets can be extremely
expensive, and those costs get passed through
directly to launch costs. This is why, even though
the cost of delivery payloads to space is falling
significantly on a per kilo basis, individual
launches are still millions of dollars. In fact,
the cheapest rocket on a per-launch basis right
now is provided by Astra, and it’s still around $3
million dollars. But SpaceRyde will offer launches
for one third that cost and has plans to quickly
push the price below a million dollars per launch.
This could be really disrupting at scale and it’s
incredibly impressive for such a small company.
After all, Astra has raised hundreds of millions
of dollars and is a public company. SpaceRyde
has raised less than $5 million dollars so far.
Leveraging existing and reliable technology is key
to so many startup success stories, but the only
reason balloons are so widely accepted in the
aerospace industry is because they’ve been in
use for over a hundred years now. All the way back
in 1912, an Austrian physicist named Victor Hess
used a hot air balloon to measure radiation levels
in the atmosphere. At the time, people believed
that radiation came from the earth, so the higher
you went, the lower the radiation would be, but
his measurements showed that the radiation levels
actually increased at high altitudes, suggesting
that the radiation was coming from space. He had
essentially discovered cosmic rays and he won the
Nobel Prize in Physics for his work. Flash forward
to 1949, and balloons again played a critical role
in atmospheric research. A group of American
naval scientists attached a rocket to a balloon
and launched it off of the U.S.S Norton Sound.
They called this rocket-balloon a “rockoon” and
even though it did successfully launch the rocket,
the fact that they couldn’t steer the contraption
really limited its usefulness. But SpaceRyde has
solved this problem with their second key piece
of technology: the rocket carrier. “Rocket Carrier
is the key ingredient of this business” No one is
going to pay SpaceRyde to launch their satellite
into orbit if they can’t guarantee where it will
wind up orbiting. A big part of the SpaceRyde
value proposition is that small satellite
companies can not only choose when to launch, but
they can decide the exact orbit that they want for
their satellite. That type of customizability is
largely unattainable via larger launch companies,
unless of course you’re willing to fork over the
millions of dollars it costs to cover the entire
launch. The SpaceRyde rocket carrier attaches
the rocket to the balloon and, more importantly,
makes sure that the rocket is pointing in the
right direction when it launches. The carrier
itself looks kind of like a quadrotor drone,
but there are some really important calculations
going on to make subtle corrections and make
sure the rocket is aligned properly at launch.
Air launches have been tried before, but they’ve
never really made much economic sense. The most
well-known air-launched rocket is the Northrop
Grumman Pegasus, which has been in operation since
1990. Even though Pegasus has had a solid track
record over the last thirty years. It still costs
$40 million dollars per launch and has a host of
other problems. Back in 2012, Elon Musk actually
addressed the Pegasus vehicle directly: “When
you drop the rocket, you have a slight problem
because you're not going in the right direction.
If you see what Orbital Sciences did with Pegasus,
they had the delta wing to do the turning
maneuver. And then you added this wing which
is added mass. And the net is that it’s not
great. They started out with the Pegasus air
launch vehicle and subsequently they haven’t done
any air launch vehicles.” Simply put: That delta
wing on top of the Pegasus rocket is inefficient.
But SpaceRyde doesn’t need one of those on their
rocket because the rocket carrier can position
the rocket automatically before it launches.
It’s an interesting situation, where advances
in software lead to simpler hardware solutions.
Similar to how self-driving cars have been able to
move away from complicated lidar systems and just
use normal cameras because of advances in machine
learning. This is always a great place to be in as
a startup. Software is getting better at a much
faster rate than hardware, so anytime you can
leverage the cutting edge of software development,
you’ll have an advantage. And Sohrab knows this
intimately. Before he founded SpaceRyde, he
actually worked on self-driving cars at Cruise
Automation. While there, he worked on Planning
and Controls, which has a remarkable amount of
overlap with the work he’s doing now at SpaceRyde.
See every autonomous vehicle has to do two things.
First, it had to perceive the world, which
basically means stitching together all the
camera and sensor data into a 3d representation.
Kind of like a video game. Then, the system has to
decide what to do with that data, where to
actually drive the car safely, which means
planning out a safe path and then sending inputs
to the steering wheel and gas pedal accordingly.
Sohrab worked on that second part at Cruise, and
it’s a perfect fit for SpaceRyde. The perception
problem is a lot simpler in a balloon, since
there are no pedestrians to deal with up in
the sky. But controlling the rocket carrier is
remarkably similar to controlling a car. When
the team goes to launch a balloon, they know the
general trajectory and can plan out a basic course
of action. But once everything lifts off, the
autonomous systems have to take over. Being able
to reliably steer the carrier without a pilot
is really tricky, but doing this with software
means it’s ultimately more reliable and more
affordable. So once the balloon is up there, and
the rocket carrier is in the right position. What
happens? Well, they have to launch the rocket.
But SpaceRyde rockets are custom made to take
advantage of the high altitude. “When you look
at rockets they are often tall and sender. There
is a reason. Because you are minimizing drag.
There is no drag concern when you are launching
at 30 kilometer altitude. So your rocket can be
short and chubby. And a fat rocket is actually
a good rocket.” This “fat” rocket design is more
than just funny though. It actually serves
a very specific purpose. Although the design
is unorthodox, these SpaceRyde “fat” rockets find
the perfect balance between structural integrity,
fuel efficiency, and payload capacity. This is
super critical, because SpaceRyde is all about
unlocking the small payload delivery market, which
is actually growing incredibly quickly. Pretty
much everyone knows about StarLink at this point,
but global internet is far from the only useful
application for small satellites. Increasingly,
satellites are getting smaller and smaller, all
while being more versatile and useful. This can be
hard to visualize, because when most of us think
about satellites we imagine the hubble telescope
or the international space station. You know, the
type of space stuff that’s big enough to point a
camera at. But satellites are getting small, like,
really small. Traditionally, a small satellite is
defined as anything under one thousand kilograms.
But SpaceRyde is only planning on carrying between
80 and 150 kilograms. That’s not a problem though
because micro satellites or “cubesats” typically
weigh less than 100 kilograms, with some as light
as just 10 kilos. There are also “nanosatellites”
now that weigh under 10 kilos, “picosatellites”
that weigh less than one kilo, and people are even
prototyping “femto-satellites” that weigh less
than 100 grams. At that point, it’s basically
just a simple chip floating around up there,
but as we’ve seen with smartphones, you can fit a
lot on a single chip these days. So, we have a few
technology trends all accelerating and converging
at the same time to make this a reality. Demand
for satellites is increasing exponentially,
satellites are getting smaller and smaller,
and autonomous control software is getting
better. All of these trends point to an easy
win for SpaceRyde right? Well, not so fast. Sohrab
has been working on this for the past five years
and I could tell from my conversation with him
that it hasn’t all been easy. First off, he’s
doing all of this in Canada, which hasn’t had an
active launch program in the country for decades.
Canada does have astronauts, but they partner
with the United States and European Space Agency
for actual launch capabilities. Fortunately,
Sohrab has an amazing partner in his wife and
co-founder Saharnaz. She has an MBA and serves
as SpaceRyde’s chief operating officer, so when
it was time to work with the Canadian government
to get regulatory approval, she stepped up and got
it done in record time. Often the best founding
teams have different but complementary skill sets.
After all, it doesn’t matter how well designed
your rocket is, if no one will let you launch it.
But there’s one more key takeaway that I love from
this story, and it’s about determination. Sohrab
probably could have coasted as an engineer in
Silicon Valley for his entire career. Cruise was
a massive success and he was there early, but he
wanted to pursue something bigger. “We are running
out of resources on the planet” He clearly cares
deeply about space and what it can unlock for
humanity broadly. Lots of people aspire to work in
amazing industries and have an impact when they're
young, but then they get caught on a particular
treadmill and lose sight of their original goal.
Sorhab took a lot of risk by switching industries
after leaving Cruise. He probably could have
worked at any self-driving company, but he
chose to pursue something bigger. And he
didn’t just risk a few resume bullet points.
He actually took out a second mortgage just to
pay for SpaceRyde’s rocket testing facility.
No one would rent him land to test rockets,
which is honestly kind of understandable, so he
just did it himself. I love that attitude. When
you’re working at a big company, enjoying free
lunches, it can be hard to take a leap of faith
and go build something in a garage. But I’m
certain that when Sohrab looks back on his
time building rockets in his garage, he won’t
regret one minute of it. Thanks for watching.